hey all you rock and roller teeny bopper
hop sock and kids your old music Maven
here Michael Knowles I have been asked
to put all of my cultural and musical
expertise to the Forefront for a song
called girls like girls this is by the
artist Haley kiyoku it has 149 million
views online right now
The Producers have not told me very much
about this video except I have to infer
from the song title is this this is a
lesbian thing guys
okay something like that they tell me
all right well I bear no responsibility
for whatever sort of deviant Madness is
going to ensue but I will try to analyze
this and in so doing analyze our whole
culture take it away
yeah
[Music]
by the way in my experience girls hate
girls
I have almost never met two women who
genuinely like each other
[Music]
[Applause]
boys
[Music]
scared to let your guard down boys
boys
tell the neighbors I'm not sorry if I'm
breaking walls
that was the boyfriend not noticing this
this very bizarre tension between his
girlfriend and that other girl
[Music]
they say the girl's sister Maybe
girls like girls like boys do nothing
new that's true lesbians have
existed in the popular imagination for
all of human history
Aristophanes talks about this in the
Symposium that all people are born with
their other half out there for some
people some boys the other half is a
girl some girls either half as a girl
some boys ever have as a boy that's an
old idea
[Music]
[Applause]
we could be everything that we would
ever need this is the sticking point and
I suspect that most people in our
culture agree with this idea even the
conservatives the libs obviously do who
are promoting all this kind of stuff but
the conservatives I think accept this
too and it's the idea that men don't
really need women and women don't really
need men I don't want to play with you
anymore when in fact one can have a good
life in consecrated celibacy one can
have a good life after the death of one
spouse I'm not denying that but men are
made to be complementary to women women
are made as complementary to men and men
and women are not the same
that's the big divide in our culture
right now some people in our culture
believe that men and women are exactly
the same that includes the feminists
that includes the gay rights activists
that includes the transgender activists
that includes the radical individualists
they believe that every person is not
fundamentally a man or fundamentally a
woman or fundamentally even a religious
being but just fundamentally an
individual undifferentiated and then the
conservatives believe no we're actually
born into society not as just these kind
of undefined atoms but with a real shape
with a body shape and with a role and
with a purpose and so we all have
purposes this this life the steers
tumbler has the purpose of bringing
delicious salty leftist ears into my
mouth this microphone has the purpose of
transmitting the dulcer tones of my
voice to all of you out there in
Internet land and our bodies have a
purpose too and a male body the purpose
of our sexual organs is for the opposite
sex and specifically for procreation
within the context of marriage for the
good houses and the generation and
education of children but as that goes
away then we're left with this rather
shallow idea which is that you and I of
the same sex or whatever we can be
everything that we need but there is
actually more to life than just girls my
12 year old Michael might not have
accepted that statement that there's
more to life than girls but there
actually is more life than girls and
there's more to life than just boys
there's more to life than just this and
just that actually we are made for one
another and we can complement one
another not just merely reflect
ourselves and the other person right now
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles we all know about the big
wireless companies out there they lock
you into these horrendous contracts and
if you try to get out of them early they
tack on outrageous charges that is why I
made the switch to Pure Talk Wireless
where there are no hidden fees no
contracts and no hassle pure talk to us
customer service team has helped so many
people make the switch in as little as
10 minutes you are even able to keep
your phone number Pure Talk has a range
of affordable plans to choose from you
can find the perfect option for your
needs unlimited talk text plenty of data
just thirty dollars a month their 5G
service is super fast consistent does
not drop calls you can get the same
coverage you're used to at half the rate
that you're currently paying Pure Talk
saves the average family over nine
hundred dollars per year not only will
you save money but you will also get the
satisfaction of knowing you're
supporting a great American company the
CEO and chairman of pure talk is a US
military veteran when you become a Pure
Talk customer you are given the option
to support America's Warrior partnership
which is an organization that works to
prevent veteran suicide go to
puretalk.com and to promo code and I'll
save 50 5-0 off your first month
puretalk.com promo code knows Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless
[Music]
gotta get it with you
[Applause]
[Music]
you gotta get with you
the vision of the music video is that
boys are really terrible and they're
bullish and they're stupid and they're
vulgar and they're actually kind of
abusive too and they're gonna grab women
and this does speak to a serious aspect
of lesbianism which is that I'm not
saying all girls who like girls that way
but for a disproportionate number of
lesbians they become lesbians after they
suffer some kind of sexual trauma at the
hands of men so that part that part is
realistic but you can see how the vision
is totally skewed because in the vision
of the music video women are are made to
have sex with women and women are all
great and men are all terrible and
there's no reason that any woman would
want anything to do with them keep going
[Music]
nothing
nothing new
[Music]
[Applause]
boy
is that it be right now now the music's
coming back up oh here we go this is the
kiss right
are you kidding me
[Music]
oh yeah that's realistic this young
younger presumably and smaller girl is
just beating up this bigger guy right
obviously there's a lot of Fantastical
thinking going on and imagery going on
in this music video but the most absurd
of all and you see this throughout the
popular culture is this idea that small
little girls can just by virtue of their
own Brute Force beat up much bigger guys
that cannot happen that does not ever
happen and I talked to Millennials I
talk to Men Women everybody and they
actually believe what they see in the
movies which is that physically small
little girls can just beat up much
larger guts that that is not realistic
actually this is one of the arguments
for the Second Amendment is it because
men are much physically stronger than
women women need something to equalize
the playing field if they're going to be
out walking around alone which would be
a gun and to tell women otherwise
is just completely irresponsible and and
furthermore the idea that this boyfriend
would come out and just start feeding up
these women because they almost kiss
first of all in our depraved day and age
the the boyfriend would probably come
out and get a kick out of it you know
he'd probably encourage it to happen but
furthermore uh that that's not the
reaction the guy the guy would probably
be pretty peeved that his girlfriend is
kissing anybody else let alone a woman
or he might find it kind of titillating
and weird but the idea that the man
would come out and just start punching
women that's absurd that just that just
is very unlikely to happen in our
culture but it does feed into The
Narrative of men bad women good that's
why no one should ever be attracted to
man in any way especially women because
women are girls are made for girls in
the way that boys think that they are
made for girls but they're really not
keep going
[Music]
is
it's funny they they actually cover up
the kiss
so they keep whenever they go in for a
kiss they kind of turn their heads or
it's covered up by the hair and it
doesn't seem believable put a pause
there I don't mean just to criticize the
acting of these young ladies they're
doing a fine job in the music video but
you can even see from the performance
this is unnatural whatever you want to
say about it okay I'm not delving into
the entire issue of lesbianism but it's
not normal
it's not natural behavior and you see
that reflected even in the performance
of it and even in the fact that the
director and cinematographer don't don't
show it totally head on they allude to
it they kind of cover it up with the
hair then there's a hug at the end
because they know it's not the same
thing as when Prince Charming rides up
on the White Horse and whips up the
Damsel in Distress and plants a big
smooch on her it's not it's different
because men and women are different
doesn't know
[Music]
nothing new nothing new that's true
subversive and Fantastical imagery is
nothing new and it is true that
throughout all of human history there
have been eccentric expressions of our
sexual desires this is a fallen and
quirky world that is true but just
because something happens does not mean
that it is ordered to happen that way
and that it is necessarily something
that one should aim for or attempt to
normalize the existence of the abnormal
is not an argument that that which is
normal I either is not normal or should
not be pursued girls might like girls
but they do not like girls like boys do
see you next time
[Music]